التنين او الصقر المقاتل هذا ما يطلق على
طائره اف 16 واحده من اكثر المقاتلات
النفاثه انتاجا في التاريخ بسبب امتلاكها
العديد من المميزات تعد من اهم الطائرات
الحربيه المقاتله خفيفه الوزن ولها قدره
على الدفاع والهجوم والقتال الجوي يصل
مداها الى اربعه الاف ومئتين 220 كلم اي
انها قادره على الوصول الى العمق الروسي
الى منطلقت من العاصمه الاوكرانيه صحيح ان
اف 16 قادره على حمل صواريخ متنوعه ومنها
رؤوس نوويه الا ان ارسالها لاوكرانيا
سيكون مهمه لرجسيه صعبه فهذه طائرات تتطلب
مدارجه طويله وعاليه الجوده وهو ما تفتكر
اليه اوكرانيا ويسهل على روسيا اكتشافها
وتدميرها بالاضافه الى ضروره وجود انظمه
التواصل وتكامل على الارض لا لهذه الطائره
ان تحلق دون محطات رصد ترسم لها الطريقه
وتحدد لها الاهداف